intéressant je dirais même plus
intéressant depuis une semaine tintin
est l'invité de charleville mézières
toute la ville vit au rythme du héros de
hergé
une aubaine pour les teintes in all of
de 7 77 ans
est ce que tu peux arriver avec un par
jour pourquoi les antilles il est bon d
aventurier et charmeur de toi alors est
ce que tu te marierait avec tintin ni
pourquoi parce que y
il fait ils voyagent partout il a même
s'ils voyagent partout tu seras jamais
avec lui
magie gras cuit à gaza sur quoi est ce
que je la trouve sexy toi alors c'est
peut-être pas sexy mais décadente la
castafiore
c'est du moins ainsi que la voie la
plasticienne blandine titeux cette
interprétation personnelle des
personnages d'hergé
ils sont 21 artistes peintres sculpteurs
ou photographes locaux à la livrée au
public jusqu'au 7 avril dans différents
lieux de la ville
vraiment pour moi la grande période
d'hergé le grand démarrage c'est le
lotus bleu ou hergé commence vraiment à
se documenter à être précis il va pas
faire un album comme ça même par exemple
si je peux citer un exemple par rapport
au tintin au pays des soviets où il ne
va prendre comme base qu'un seul livre
donc à partir de ce moment-là 'sinon il
faut être beaucoup plus précis il ne
faut pas faire les choses que par
rapport à une seule donnée à cette
époque s'estompe l'anti communisme
primaire d'hergé c'est aussi la période
où il rencontre ochang entre les deux
hommes
naîtra une forme d'amour particulière
qu'on appelle l'amitié